foreign
why do I hate my newborn so much
let me just say this saying that that
out loud was scary right it's the first
time yeah okay you're not crazy
and I don't think you're a bad guy
good why do I feel so bad yeah
[Music]
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
show where we walk alongside you when
you're struggling with mental health
issues and struggling with your
relationships and just trying to figure
out what to do next in your marriage in
your dating life whatever is going on
we're here to walk alongside you give me
a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's one eight four four
six nine three three two nine one go to
John deloney.com ask
and if you want the greatest supplements
on planet Earth
again that's just me go to thorn.com
t-h-o-r-n-e.com slash you slash deloni
the letter U
t-h-o-r-n-e slash U slash deloni for 25
off everything I got
uh it's a partnership we have and it's
what me and my family take almost
exclusively and we have for years and
years and years before I start working
here um it's the best of the best of the
best and um it's a great hookup for all
you guys so uh everybody listening all
you men and women so uh thorn.com
go check it out all right let's go to
um Jacob in Dallas what's up Jacob
hey how's it going I'm good man how
about you
uh
uh a lot of things I don't know
surviving there you go hey sometimes
it's the best we can do man what's going
on yeah
um well
not sure
maybe if there's a right or wrong way to
ask this just jump on in don't get so
hate so much hate but uh
why do I hate my newborn so much
ah tell me about it
um what's newborn's name
Charlie Charlie boy or girl
boy okay how old
uh Saturday will be eight weeks eight
weeks all right tell me about it
um
I mean
actually let me ask you some more direct
questions because I know that's a
let me just say this saying that that
out loud was scary right
it's the first time yeah okay you're not
crazy
and I don't think you're a bad guy
good
why do I feel so bad yeah
we'll we'll walk through it and I I have
a suspicion already but we'll get there
okay but I want you to know I don't
think you're a bad guy I don't think
you're crazy okay
okay cool
so tell me about the pregnancy
um you married I mean uh yeah just we
got married actually when she was a
basically eight months eight nine months
pregnant so oh wow okay so you just jump
to the deep end here
yeah okay how long have y'all dating how
long were y'all
about a year and a half okay
um and how old are you
21 21 okay
um
I mean I was gonna marry her anyway so
that's kind of everybody's like for sure
you were Jacob sure you were so
um she gets pregnant and you'll get
married right before how was the
delivery
uh it all went very smoothly
that was all all good
um
and then you were told or anything you
were told by every
old man young man everybody
in your life that this was gonna be some
Magic Moment Everything's Gonna Change
in the before and the after and this and
that
and that didn't happen right
not not at all okay
and then when it doesn't happen you
almost start grasping for it like where
is it where is it where is it
and I feel like I'm trying to force it
there you go yeah
so let's go with the obvious then we're
going to work down to some of the more
um
but I think my guess what I think it
actually is going on here
um your world has exploded right
it's crumbling tell me about it
um well not that everything was awesome
beforehand or perfect or I should it was
awesome but it wasn't perfect right
um
I don't know I mean so I had just moved
to me and my
then girlfriend now wife moved to Dallas
in 2021
um so I was 19 when I moved out here
um
and we had just gotten together at that
point but I dropped out of school
um
and we were just trying to figure figure
this out and uh got a job and I've just
been kind of working since then but I
I don't know I've super neglected being
healthier or
you know whatever especially since he's
been born you know
just yummy candies and pizza literally
pizza rolls every night
Diet Coke we're making fun of me Jacob
stop making fun of me hey all right so
let's let's don't blow by this you're
21.
your world just exploded
your girlfriend overnight became your
wife
faster than you anticipated right
um what limited money you had it's
completely gone
and you're probably yeah probably in the
negative
um yeah your body feels terrible
and you haven't slept
and at the end of that rainbow is
supposed to be this life-changing
being
yeah and one thing I hear and it's
supposed to make all that worth it right
and it's that's what they say that's
what they say and I want to let you know
the reason I'm telling you you're not
crazy
it's one of the most common one of the
most common conversations I have with
brand new dads behind closed doors
is
I've never poured into something I've
never given every thought every
ounce of everything I got I'm beyond
tired in other other worldly tired
in this little being won't even
acknowledge me
this little being doesn't like me just
wants my wife just wants baby's mom and
I there's no psychology there's no
physiology for putting so much into this
idea of love and not getting anything
back
yeah
yeah see what I'm saying
yeah like
it was gonna be this big hole ta-da and
it's not just when you pick him up he
screams at you
just screams yes
and because you're a caring guy
and I don't I don't say this in the
pejorative way like you're just young
like you haven't you haven't had a lot
of experiences with with
kids with Messy relationships
um
it's easy to personify that well it's a
person it's easy to make that kid 22
years old
and if you hug somebody you loved and
they screamed every time and shoved you
away that would that would be
devastating
and instead of realizing this is just
like
a bundle of nerve endings that doesn't
know up from down it's you know it's
just but it's easy to say hey it's just
a person it's a being I'm your dad
make all of this other crap better
the baby just goes right
yeah yeah for sure okay
so let's let's not blow past that
also
paternal postpartum depression is a very
real thing
okay
um
there is sometimes some men experience
an off the table falling off like a
cliff drop in their testosterone after
they have kids in fact there's some
studies about testosterone kids men who
play with their kids more more active
with their kids their testosterone will
will drop off
some after the baby is born it falls off
the map
and so everything feels like it's gone
dark like their Shades pulled on
everything Shades pull on that that
spark used to have with your wife Shades
pull on
um the joy you have going to work the
shades pull down on this little human
who's taken everything from you
including the woman you loved and all of
your money and all of your resources and
all of your time and all of your energy
and all of your sleep and all that stuff
and it's just underwater
and then this little baby becomes the
epicenter of your
depression most men experience
depression
as rage anger
hate
okay yeah that's showing up everywhere
right you're probably although you say I
hate my in my newborn I hate my infant I
bet you are not a peach to be around to
anybody else either right
no no
he said nah nah man no you're not so
um I work with middle schoolers all day
holy smokes I yell at them I mean I'm a
tennis coach so don't be all the kids
Jacob don't be that coach okay listen
I never ever ever ever ever want to
diagnose somebody from this show okay
that's that would be irresponsible of of
me and all that
um I do want you
to go talk to a doctor
okay and if you've listened to this show
long enough I rarely say that I'll tell
people to see a counselor I'll tell
people to write a letter to them former
selves and all that kind of stuff you
need to go see a doctor okay
okay
how long has this under current this
this time this uh trying to think that
Sun's nerdy this lower level how long
have you been running pretty low
um
before you moved
I I've been
I was depressed all all throughout high
school well I was severely bullied in
Middle School in high school
um and was been so I dealt with a lot of
that and I was finally feeling good when
I moved down here okay
um and then
it's all kind of just
it hit me like a ton of bricks like I I
swear this came out of nowhere you know
walking down the street and the piano
drops on your head that's exactly right
and if you get your t-tested in it
um and it shows that it fell off a cliff
it literally did you get hit by a piano
and maybe that's not it maybe that's not
it but everything you're telling me says
and you go talk to a doctor and then
you're gonna end up
there in the Dallas area which has got
some incredible resources
um
going to sit and talk to somebody
and I need you to hear me say this for a
living
and I've got a two-hour appointment this
Friday
okay
you're not broken you're not weird
you're not a coward I would say the
broken cowardly thing to do is just to
keep plowing forward
that's so tempting I know it is and then
you become like every other man in
America
overweight exhausted frustrated doesn't
like their family their family doesn't
like them
their face buried in their phone or
their face buried in some
pornography on their laptop like you see
what I'm saying I don't I don't want
that life for you
I don't want it either okay
so you're not crazy you're not broken
there's not quote unquote something
wrong with you
but your body's struggling right now and
that's all right
for for
your sake for this kid's sake for your
wife's sake
will you make a call will you go see
somebody
I want yeah
yeah let me say it this way what I'm
gonna say is it's not fair and I would
say it a little more gently if we were a
meeting in person but
I need to be sensationalist for this
show okay
yeah
um
if you don't make a call you are
choosing to remain Where You Are
okay don't make that choice you're worth
more than that choice
it says little Charlie
so is your new wife Fair
okay is it
I can't solve this over the radio and I
can't solve it at all it's gonna be it's
gonna be up to you to do the work does
it give you any peace
to know that there's this is not
uncommon that you're not defective and
messed up in a psychopath
yeah okay it does I mean I don't yeah it
does okay
do you ever have any thoughts of hurting
this kid
no not anything legitimate but you know
crying at 3 30 in the morning it's
probably just a
I might just drop you yeah and walk into
the room and go back to sleep yep
go see somebody okay
and
don't read the YouTube comments on this
one okay
people are cruel people are cruel
hey will you do me a favor will you call
me after you talk to a doctor I'd love
to hear
um they run some blood tests on you and
they sit with you for a bit I'd love to
hear what they have to say but and by
the way when you go be a hundred percent
honest
um because you hedged even a little bit
with me which I understand we're on the
radio and all that but be a hundred
percent honest okay
you're not crazy they're not gonna lock
you up
yeah and you've had that thought too
haven't you
yeah yes
yeah you get real dark thoughts just
postpartum you get real dark thoughts
that get loopy on you you try to solve
them and then you start imagining all
kinds of End of Time stuff wow
it's your body trying to take care of
you man it's got a little sideways let's
go sit with the doctor
and then you'll end up having to sit
with some other people probably in a
group of some sort possibly with a
counselor great man it's awesome and
while you're there
you can be able to exercise some of
those demons from middle school
the Looney Tune Middle School Bratz
brutal to you
and that low level grind you've been
doing since you were in college and
Beyond
listen
you're worth so much
make that choice
for an exciting Venture of a peaceful
Life we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself
it's easy to get caught up in what
people need from you and want from you
and never think about what you need and
then you end up too stretched out burned
out all of the madness of our current
world resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with the licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's a better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Anna in
Tallahassee what's up Anna
I'm actually home with covet so not much
to do now oh gosh I'm not laughing at
you I'm just laughing like oh that's no
good
yeah I know I actually just traveled
outside of the country and that's what I
get so here we are that's what you get
some kind of cosmic punishment you will
stay in America
the latest um literature hopefully I
can't catch it over the phone like this
Anna if you give me covet I'm gonna be
not happy with you okay let's do this
what's up yes so my original question
was I want to understand why I'm
choosing a life of misery
um my email was very vague but uh just a
little background I'm 25 years old a mom
of two under two
um and a husband uh you know been
married since 2019 however he's been in
my life since I was 15.
um so we I want to say we kind of grew
up together
um however
I'm at a point in my life where I have
undiagnosed you know depression anxiety
um how do you know
well I started going to a therapist and
she said hey I think this is what you
have so it's not undiagnosed it is
diagnosed
Yeah well yeah
yeah I bet well counselors I mean
counselors in mental health
professionals of all kind are I mean
they've got to go through their
licensure so you've been officially
diagnosed if if a licensed mental health
professional said you have this which
again I hate that language with all my
guts I hate that language but if they
told you you have this then you've got a
diagnosis okay so they said you've got
anxiety and depression
yeah
um just because I may have had some
Depression years back but again didn't
see a therapist or anything before
um however had children and I feel like
that kind of postpartum depression kind
of may have you know made it more
pronounced
um and so going through all that with
them
um that's that's how they ended with
that conclusion
um
so hold on before we go further
see what before we go further I want you
to hear me say something really
important for you okay in a million
years I'm not going to dispute what your
person told you okay
rest on that they're licensed
professional and they know what they're
doing and they're not just out there
running and gunning and being idiots
cool
and
imagine what's your favorite movie of
all time
um Forrest Gump Forrest Gump imagine
you're watching all of Forrest Gump
and there's that scene when he's running
and you took your phone and you snapped
a photo of him running
that is your diagnosis it's not the
whole movie
it's a snapshot of your life and
actually if you just looked at this
picture of a bearded man running
you would think the movie is about
something very different than what it
actually is about right
right okay so this is not your destiny
this is not the rest of your life this
is not a a
confirmed death sentence
okay
this is a series of experiences that
you've been having for an for a period
of time and somebody says all right
took a picture here's where we are right
now
okay okay um
yeah
and
my escorts of seven
um
and I have sometimes a trauma that is
still there
um that I have that probably probably
um the less you know
um we've talked a little bit about it in
counseling I've mentioned that but it
still sums up a lot
um
and so now
I'm at a point where
I wake up every day I do what I need to
do however
there's no time for me there's
um priorities that take precedent over
me and
how do I
choose me and
I put my kids first
um
because of the mom you know that
as soon as they were born they took
priority
um
and
yeah I just I don't know how to
be happy and make the decisions I need
to make
and create a better life not only for
them but for me yeah
growing up was really hard
right you've got Aces score of seven
that means you grew up in a in a blender
yeah and your body's been through some
pretty awful things huh
oh yeah yeah
a couple of things at play here number
one I just want to call out the obvious
you've been with your husband for a long
time yeah I think you used the words we
grew up together
okay
what that means is without him realizing
it I'm not saying he's a bad guy
I'm saying
any time
you rise up you begin thinking about
healing you begin to alter the dynamic
the homeostatic relationship between you
and him
his body gets out of whack
and it wants things to go back the way
they were
and so your healing
your I'm sick and tired of being sick
and tired I've had enough
is going to have to include him
and he is going to have to be along for
the ride
meaning your healing is going to be
disruptive to him and it should be and
that's the way things are gonna be
okay
okay here's what I'm telling you that
first you cannot do this by yourself
and you can't do it without
um Rippling the water
somebody with an Asus score of seven
ninety nine hundred and
what's the word 999 times out of a
thousand
got really good
at making sure everybody else was okay
that's how you survived
Fair
yeah
so much so that you've outsourced that
to uh 19 month old and a
four-month-old
I gotta make sure they're okay then I
can exhale I gotta make sure he's okay
then I can exhale
and so for instance here's a simple
thing let's say you decide like I'm
gonna I I want to lose weight and I want
to be healthy
and for two nights you cook healthy
foods you go for a walk after dinner
he's gonna show up with a pizza
on night three
not for any reason other than he's
driving home and he's like man my wife's
been doing really good the last two days
eating healthy like she deserves some
joy in her life
and then we're back to the way things
were okay so this is gonna be disruptive
I want you to get that through your
heart and through your mind
number two
I get a sense from you that you go to a
counselor and you just talk about stuff
I want you to start going to counseling
and if this isn't the right therapist I
want you to find the right one with a
spirit of I'm going to work
I'm not going just to talk about this
stuff
because quite frankly any you have had
these conversations in your mind for
your whole life right
yeah yeah
I want you to go to counseling with a
spirit of
a sledgehammer and a lunch pail I'm
going to break concrete I'm going to do
some hard work
okay okay
yeah tell me you've never seen this in
real life so this is all fantasy at this
point
describe to me what you want your body
to feel like when you walk home fast
forward three years
you've got um I don't know you might
have nine other kids by then at your
rate just kidding so you've got
um
three years from now you've done a lot
of counseling you and your husband have
reimagined your marriage and you walk in
the front door
just tell me what you would imagine that
would feel like
um
like happiness no happiness is happiness
is cotton candy and cocaine happiness is
just a high five on the trail to
wherever it is you're going
happy don't don't don't reach for
happiness that can't be your destination
because you're gonna it's got too many
off-ramps you know it would make me
really happy right now a bag of gummy
candy and a Diet Coke that'd be so
awesome
and it would make me feel terrible it
would make me really short-tempered it
would make me really want to
procrastinate these book edits and I
gotta get done and you know what I'm
saying and and
happy is when I wake up and I've had a
good night of sleep and I've taken care
of my body and my wife and I are in sync
and my kids are I could hear them
Milling around out laughing with each
other and I smile and then I think I'm
really happy right now
but that can't be the objective okay so
you walk in the front door what do you
feel
[Music]
um
I want to say good
um all right close your eyes let's do
this close your eyes okay okay you walk
through your front door
you hear one of your knuckleheaded kids
go Mom's home
and they get up and they run and they
squeeze your legs as hard as they can
and you're smiling ear to ear
you guys don't owe anybody any money
your kids are healthy
you feel good because you had a good
night's sleep
and you say all right get off get off
and they laugh and one of them shoves
the other one then they run out in the
backyard to go play
and then your husband walks out of his
back room
and he smiles real big and he says I'm
so bad you're home he drops his
shoulders and you all hug for a minute
when I say what does it feel like I'm
thinking of warmth and I'm thinking of
laughter and I'm thinking of peace and
I'm thinking of
oh yes
you've never had that walking into a
house before have you
no no
I want you that I can I want you to have
that more than anything in the world
and I need you to believe me on the
front end of this journey
100 you can get there
okay here's what it's gonna look like
understanding this radical truth your
kids can only be fully taken care of if
Mom's okay
so the best way to put your kids forward
is by taking care of their mom
now you got really young ones of course
you're gonna be exhausted you're gonna
get up in the middle of the night you
get a million diapers just getting them
in and out of the freaking bathtub is
chaos right
right that's the season you're in it's
not smooth someone for a while it's okay
I promise you man when they can go to
the bathroom on their own and get in out
of the shower it's like you got half
your life back it's amazing but that's
not you right now it's okay
okay so we're going to take this season
and we're not going to say things like
I don't have any time to take care of me
we're going to say things like I chose
not to take care of myself today
and we're going to start using that kind
of language
because then we're going to be able to
say I'm choosing to take care of myself
today
hey honey I'm getting up a little bit
early to go for a walk only 15 minutes
but I'm gonna go for a walk
hey honey I'm gonna get an app out and I
don't know how to meditate because that
sounds stupid but I'm just gonna sit
here and close my eyes put the
headphones in and just follow what those
things the breathing exercises things
tell me to do
I need you to go watch the little ones
cool
hey honey once a week gonna do a budget
with you just talk about calendar
because I have this picture in my head
where you and I can't wait to see each
other
and it's warm
and it's peaceful
and then when you go talk to a counselor
you're gonna have to be honest about
your childhood and you haven't done that
yet
give him hard and you talked around the
bush but you you have not
said here's what happened to me
right
because if you say it out loud then you
have to deal with the ramifications of
the people who should have been there to
help you weren't there or they may have
been part of the problem
yeah this journey gets hard
okay
okay and you're worth every freaking
step of it Anna okay one more thing I'm
gonna tell you I want you to make a list
on a note card
or on a piece of paper or maybe you're
crafty and you can make it look nice I
don't know how so I just gave up
okay but I want you to put five or ten
things action steps that you do every
day
that your feelings don't get a vote on
your motivation doesn't get a vote you
will do these things
I will go for a walk
I will put my hands on my kids face and
look them in the eye and kiss them on
the forehead for 30 seconds each kid
even the wiggly one
okay I will do four rounds of I don't
know 10 seconds 15 seconds of skin on
skin contact with my husband
right when we wake up right before I
leave for work right when we get home
right before we go to sleep
you can just be touched it didn't have
to be sexual just be I'm we're just
gonna Touch Feet I'm gonna hold his hand
I'm gonna put my hand on his chest and
put my face on his face which can sit
here for a second
I want you to write these things down
and I don't care if you don't feel like
it I don't care if he comes home and
he's gross and he does something stupid
I gotta get my fourth skin on skin
contact
okay feelings don't matter what we're
gonna do is we're building a new muscle
that you don't you've never had to deal
to build before
and that is discipline that is I'm worth
this even when I don't feel like it I
love myself even when myself doesn't
feel like loving me back
that's what I'm going to take care of it
okay
okay promise
yeah I'm already running I'm down yeah I
know you would because you're done
aren't you you're done with all this
yeah
hey hey I'm so so proud of you
thank you an aces of seven means you
have been through hell
and after you go through hell and you're
covered up in all these scars and you
still have stitches and burn marks
sometimes putting your hand up and
saying hey I need help
raising your hand in the old days gotcha
gotcha hit
I got you seen
so just the act of raising your hand and
saying
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired as an act of rebellion it's an act
of Courage it says hold on hold on
I'm worth being loved too
I'm done with surviving
I'm done with hating myself I'm done
with being covered up in shame all the
time it's time to be free
got a hard road ahead of you Anna it'll
be tough
[Music]
you are worth every single step and by
the way your kids are gonna get to watch
their mama
get six inches tall
this is changing her family tree your
kids are going to get to watch you and
your husband argue and try to look this
way this way and develop boundaries and
say no to your family and his family and
all and figure out a new way marriage is
going to work they get to see all that
this is changing your family tree
[Music]
so proud of you
be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hallow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we are back let's go to Matt
in the SLC out in Utah what's up Matthew
hey Dr Dean my heart is racing
Kelly doesn't even have a heart man so
it's all good just kidding hey you're
good man what's up
uh well I'm calling because I'd like to
figure out why the repression of my
self-expression causes me distress
tell me more
yeah so I I wrote a script to organize
some of this
um and it ended up being kind of like a
journal entry it definitely stopped me
or slow me down if uh it seems like a
lot but we're gonna keep it nice and
light hold on hold on
all right
how off the rails are you willing to get
oh we're we're going all the way okay
we're gonna get way off the rails so
I can tell 13 seconds into this call two
things
you are so good at repression
and you're very very smart sophisticated
even
and whatever your repression is about
has been something that you've gotten so
good at navigating
that you've created poetry and flowers
all around it
so I'm gonna challenge you I don't want
to hear your diary I want you to say it
in one sentence my name is Matt and
here's what I'm wrestling with
my name is Matt and I'm wrestling with
a lifelong repression of myself
Matt you're still doing you're still
doing it you almost got there and then
you chickened out all right let's try it
again I'm Matt and
I'm Matt and I am a lifelong liar
keep going
what do you like about getting myself
away from everyone in my life
um just about everyone in my life uh
specifically as it relates to
cross-dressing okay
hey
I want you to go backwards and own it
for a second okay
can you do that
absolutely
because we can't get anywhere if Matt
doesn't like Matt
yeah there's a lot of self-hatred there
I can feel it all I can just feel it I
can man
and if we were sitting right here the
fir I would stop all conversations and
I'd give you a hug
I appreciate it okay you would have to
buy the beers but I'd give you a hug
just kidding I'd probably want to okay
two two two guys having nachos all right
the way you introduce yourself is I'm a
lifelong liar the way I introduce you
introduce yourself is I'm a lifelong
theater performer I'm a scam artist
and I disagree
often
when we have things that we don't want
to tell anybody about
our immediate childhood environment says
if you say this out loud it's going to
get you killed
it's going to get you hurt people are
going to leave you
and so often you can call it lying fine
sometimes I call it survival
okay
yeah I want you to make peace with Matt
so tell me what tell me what we're what
we're doing you you've had you been
thinking about cross-dressing your whole
life or you have been and just hiding it
from people tell me more
yeah I I have been um
I I think it would help if I if I went
to the script I think it yeah just like
you said it paints a picture with
flowers um if you're cool with that
let's do it
um yeah so listening to your show made
me trauma that I previously disregarded
and it made me feel compelled to take
the spcc aces quiz and I scored a 10.
um my brother hey can I just stop right
second stop
I'm so sorry
uh for a while I I I thought it was an
eight and some digging got me the 10.
you just said that like you get a prize
there's no prize
yeah it depends how you cut the lines
around these things right yeah yeah
let's just say that
somebody that should have loved you and
taking care of you dragged you to hell
is that fair
yeah yeah and then you tried to get out
and they wouldn't let you
and uh they loved me the best they could
and they were great I love them still
today stop stop I'm defending them stop
I don't even know what the deal is
the person I want you defending is
little bat
okay
yeah all right so tell me keep going
with me then what yeah
uh twice I wanted to end my life and
once I tried okay
um I've sat down many bricks but still
carry some from the period and he said I
was a liar that curated my story I never
felt comfortable telling those around me
about my cross-dressing which was seldom
expressed and very personal at the time
and once I did I lost many of the people
closest to me and it really was a
self-fulfilling prophecy that the the
thing that I was shut out for wasn't
necessarily the cross-dressing but the
the closure that that I was a walking
liar
are those your words are theirs
theirs okay
um
one example uh I had you know all the
groomsmen in my my wedding uh all but
one had known about me uh and then once
the that one last one did find out uh he
rallied the whole group against me and
then I was invited to one of their
weddings uh which which my wife and I
flew out to and I was threatened with
physical violence and I'd say I stared
it in the face I I stayed through the
party
um and
I don't I don't think I've quite set
that one down yet I I
miss them horribly
um and and I did catch on the last call
that that ability to try and soothe
others I felt like I was there for all
these people through a lot of their
darkest times a lot of the hardest
things for them and then just one one
whiff of who I am
um and and they all turn their backs
I'm sorry man
okay
so now now we're through that the heavy
stuff but um hey we're not getting
through this for a long time I mean
I mean that
fear of abandonment
is one of the great human fears
one of the things that our we our bodies
we fake and we maneuver and we
cheer and rally I mean look at political
rallies there's no way all the people in
those things believe a hundred percent
but were willing to go along with it
because of fear of Abandonment why
because true abandonment
feels like death
then you experience
really did feel like it yes
because that version of your life is
over
it's over the one that had where people
had your back and that y'all could tell
each other everything and you showed up
for each other at 2 30 in the morning
they left you
and here's why I keep here's why I want
to stay there for just one second
it's easy to point fingers and it's easy
to miss them but you gotta go through
grief you got to sit in it
and it's your body's way of saying this
happened this was and that is no more
I hate that you're feeling just I hate
your friends I'm sorry no I'm even just
hearing it from you saying that that
they they left you they were gone
um did breathe a huge shy of relief it
was kind of nice to hear it not from
someone else and not or from someone
else and not not trying to figure it out
there's nothing to figure out man when
your friends abandon you to your face
and let's go this far even if they're
right like let's came out and said hey
I'm having an affair with my with
somebody else's wife and this and that
and your friends are like I'm out of
here dude
that still hurts right
yeah or if you come out and say I'm
struggling with X or I've got this or I
ca anytime your Rider dies look at you
and say
oh
and they're out
it's death it's devastating that old
life you had is now over and you got to
figure out out of the ash what to do
next
and if you have an Aces score of 10
often our friends become our families
they take on a larger than life role and
how we love and how we feel safe
and How We Do Life shoulder to shoulder
Andy Captain kneecap and
I don't know there's just something
profound when parents leave family
leaves all right that sucks it's
heartbreaking it's hard all that
friends bail on us all right so tell me
about cross-dressing how long since
you're a little kid you were older tell
me about it
yeah since I was very little and it
happened intermittently
um kind of on and off for periods it was
something that I could always kind of
bury for for periods at a time
um and then let me ask you this and I'm
doing this
partly as educational for me because
you're teaching me and for the audience
okay so this isn't gratuitous
um
tell me about was it just
you felt a sense of Anxiety Relief by
just wearing
comfortable underwear or when people are
out of the house you had a stash of a
dress somewhere like tell me tell me
tell me what it looked like
yeah
um I think more curiosity at first like
early on I remember stealing some like
uh cool from the the Thanksgiving
display it was like a little material
and I'd like put that around myself as a
skirt and it was something that I'd done
by myself and then kind of hid away okay
and um
there were other times uh like at a
family event I found myself in in like a
Cosmetics drawer and saw uh like like
maxi pads and I didn't know what the
hell they were but it was just this this
intense curiosity for what it was
and then that evolved into when I was
I would say like Middle School into high
school age I I started um finding
articles of clothing that I could wear
on my own secretly that I'd hide away
there's still somewhere in my yard
there's a hole that I buried like a
skirt that I was afraid someone would
find
I'm just laughing at like some Farmer's
gonna be moaning around someday and be
like uh
um so was when you said I was like six
inches deep for real
so when you're talking about like
discreet we're talking about socks and
underwear no
um more like skirts I went to a private
school and there was there was uniforms
associated with it and so in the lost
and found I'd like found a skirt that I
could take with me okay okay
and so how is this is your does your
wife know yeah so that's one of the big
things I take solace is that the day she
met me I had my nails painted and
um we hit it off so great that day
and then that that night one of these
friends that ended up leaving me said
you gotta call her man she uh she thinks
you're uh you know the hard f word and
uh you got to set things right with her
and tell her that it was a joke or
something
and uh so I talked to her about it and
oh so when she met you she thought you
were gay
yeah um she didn't but but he said yeah
yeah okay right okay
right to kind of maybe protecting the
group I don't know what he was what his
plan was
um I'll pause here real quick because I
know this is gonna I can already see
where this is headed there's something
called um I just lost it what is it
called uh
fundamental attribution error you ever
heard me talk about that on the show
no it's when we get into somebody else's
head
and try to come up with a story as to
why they did what they did why they said
what they said what I would tell you is
fundamental attribution error is a
complete and utter waste of our time and
I would tell you stay out of people's
heads who cares like the guy I live
there the guy I know I know it does and
it's it's uh haunting It's haunting
because the stories you create are
always infinitely worse because you are
the always The Whipping Boy in those
stories
and it's hard to look at someone and be
like
even if I had been gay like
you're not gonna be my friend are you
gonna lie but you see what I'm saying
like it's hard to even go there and
challenge your friend it's easy just to
look in the mirror and be like I suck
which is what most of us do so status
people's heads is what I'd say you have
enough going on inside of yours I'm
confident right
yeah I mean I mean that's so much the
core of what what ails me is is this
this living in people's heads and having
this dialogue that I'm finding more and
more isn't true that's right
that's right
it's disorienting okay so your uh your
wife knows right
yeah so she knew from the get-go
um and as our relationship grew so did
uh my expressions in it it was something
that we shared together and it wasn't
any anything that she ever tried to
restrict my expression but more just
made sure that I was
um
like let's say appropriate for the
weather or whatever the the situation
was or that I felt comfortable in my own
skin was important to her so so we all
have the same pictures and words when
you say expression are you talking about
um y'all would get together like for
movie night and you might
um wear women's clothing and you all
snuggle up on the couch and watch the
movie together are you talking about
y'all went to the movies out in public
and you went and had dinner together
um with you wearing women's clothing
early on it was a very seldom
um that we would go out in public
um
and then that grew some and we became
more comfortable doing that okay and did
she um was she on heightened alert for
people double taking or was she like
whatever this is just my husband's
Wackadoo and it's all good because I
love him
yeah and I was always kind of high alert
in those early days just thinking that
there was going to be some outward act
of violence towards me or okay something
I didn't I didn't know what I expected
it so let me ask you this when you when
you
when you call it expression when you put
on women's clothing is it an anxiety
release as though you've identified
women's clothing as something that is
that is safe and relaxing and soft and
feminine what what is it about putting
on women's clothing
or are you in the process of of
considering transition
a little column in a little column B
um I think there is like a safe bit of
it I don't
I don't consider that I'd go through any
medical procedures but even this
afternoon I got laser treatment to
remove some facial hair okay which hurts
like all because they shoot your face
with a laser yeah yeah yeah that's it's
pretty traumatic
um
but yeah
I have anxiety building and then it's
something that I do to relieve that
anxiety it's a relief okay um
but it's it's the contrary that I build
relationships and the the less that
people know that part about me and the
longer I know them the more
uh untrustworthy I feel okay
and and being outward about it I feel
like I I tear down that wall and that
people just get to see me as who I am
okay let me just say it this way I'm
gonna head directly into
this conversation in into like a I'm
gonna make a pretty direct statement and
I want you to hear me say
it's a statement I've been making for
decades across all different kinds of of
uh challenges people are experiencing
okay and so but I also know that by
making this statement it's a hot button
issue so I need to I need to know you
and I are on the same team on this is
that cool
yeah okay so when somebody calls my show
and they tell me I have anxiety
you've probably heard it I always tell
them you're experiencing anxiety
this is not
anxiety is not a core identity
and so when you tell me this is who I am
what I want to like I want to hug you
and say you are math
and this and this and this
and I know that's very unpopular because
we've in our culture currently in this
in this little moment in history we have
braided together identity and who I am
and these things that make me feel safe
for these things that make me feel less
anxious or these make things that make
me feel a little more at peace see what
I'm saying
yeah and so what I'll tell you is like
you're my brother Matt
worthy of being loved and your body goes
oh
when you put on women's clothing now I'm
open to being wrong there tell me if I'm
wrong or if that if that strikes a chord
with you
uh it definitely strikes the chord
um more process oriented but um
I I wouldn't say that you're you're
wrong it's it's just the general
behavior is
um things that I'd kind of
compartmentalized as being feminine for
fear of being found out
um like taking care of myself
hygienically
um that kind of stuff I always just
pushed off or almost went to the Other
Extreme just to just to hide it said yes
yes and yes
I think that some of the things some
things are clearly labeled feminine and
masculine and I think anybody across any
Spectrum can look at it and go yeah
that's feminine masculine and there's a
whole bunch of other stuff that is it's
a lot grayer than we like to pretend it
is right
sure yeah
um okay so you've led me here what's
like the the question that's that's
sitting with you I'm sure you've got a
bunch of questions what's what's a big
one I could help you with today yeah so
my wife and I had moved you know across
the country and it kind of came to a
head with the birth of our child I
thought that it'd be like the last time
I could put it all away and and just
kind of man up all all at once and
that'd be the end of it and it was like
the the opposite
um and and I felt more more compulsion
than ever to to just make sure that
everyone knew especially my son I didn't
think I'm turning 18 on finding out
something about me or whatever age
um I didn't think that would be healthy
for him
um but that led us to her in my in-laws
her parents uh discussing moving out
across the country and heard you say not
by their hand but in their lap um they
have to deal with me in some capacity I
don't expect them to love and embrace me
open-handed
oh open armed
um but we did end up having a
conversation about it went about as well
as it could
um and I guess the the final Stones I'm
carrying on Final breaks I'm carrying
with them is
uh that the father said
um I'm not coming here to judge anyone
um but it's something that has to be
kept a secret from anyone you know back
where we're from and
it was over the course of the next few
days I've been living in an absolutely
wonderful life my wife and I are very in
love our child is healthy everything's
good we're baby steps millionaires we
nearly paid off our house we did all the
things to to for me to feel like it
could finally express myself and uh
just being told like keep that to
yourself I don't know over the next few
days I
really just felt like I had to make
myself small again
um it went away almost immediately but
but that thought of making myself very
very small happened again and
I don't know why and because it's not
even something that I want to go back to
New York and express these things to all
these people it's
I just want to know they're in my corner
um so let me let me um is it okay if I
push on you a little bit
yeah please
um
I've
I've had I've had similar conversations
with people my whole career okay
particularly 18 to 22 year olds with the
students I was working with that were
coming to realizations of all kinds okay
and they would come some sometimes
stumbling into my office they didn't
want something to be true or they
finally wanted to say something out loud
and so
um
one thing I always told them
and again maybe I'm a wrong forsakeness
but I always told them
your parents get a minute
because
your parents have this picture that they
have had since the moment they found out
they were going to have you
and it was going to look like x y and z
and now that picture's different
and they just get a minute and they're
gonna say dumb things and they're going
to say the wrong thing and they're going
to maybe in your father-in-law's case
he loves you and sees how well you take
care of his daughter
and he loves how much how good of a
father you are and he also knows that
he's got a bunch of bigoted idiot
friends or friends or whatever
back home that will abandon him the way
your friends abandon you
and so there's some there's some place
for
compassion there's some place for
his whole picture's different now
and I always want to go on both sides of
the conversation now I've had plenty of
conversations with parents and
who have called me and said if I could
do anything in my life over again I
would have that first conversation back
right so every this whole thing is so
so messy because people want to say what
they want to say but they don't know if
they're going to say it they don't want
to be bad but they also are like hey
this is weird I've never seen this or
this isn't weird but I feel all of it's
so messy and so just the best you're
able to having a spirit of Grace
I it it not only helps that person but
man it gives you peace right
absolutely is that fair yeah
I'd like to say I don't
you know I've been listening to you for
a bit now and I don't feel like I've
held any resentment and that I'm you
know giving him Grace awesome um but
that I also don't feel that
they're um the mother may be more so but
I don't feel like it's an open
conversation or that it's something
that's Revisited and the door was kind
of shut okay and so I I never wanted to
be something so decorative but I didn't
want them to move across the country if
it was going to be an issue for them
um and I feel like like he doesn't quite
understand the extent like that it's
something that I can just hide entirely
and so I don't know how to keep that
door for conversation open with someone
that and I quote this he says there's
things that I will personally take to
the grade and this is also one of them
and so I I don't know how to talk to
someone like that
was a couple things to play here okay
first first thing here
any major change
any major change is going to affect the
relationship with people okay
that is
he gets to decide
whether he wants to be in relationship
with his wife and
her husband and their baby
and you and your wife get to decide what
being in relationship with us is going
to look like for other people
here's what we're going to say is okay
here's what we're going to say is not
okay
here's what we're going to say is
offensive in our home here's what we're
going to say is not offensive in our
home
and here's what we're going to accept
here's what we're not going to accept
and then that's just called Boundaries
and then this is this is who we're going
to be this is how we're going to roll
this is what our life is going to be and
this is what you're experiencing is
something that statistically speaking
most people will never experience but
the principles apply to everybody
in our home these are our values this is
how we're going to be
and in-laws parents friends coaches
former professors whoever if you're
going to be in our life
then these are our values these are the
jokes that are not okay
This Is How We Do Thanksgiving
and then they get that they get that
choice go ahead
if I had to put a marker on what the
value is in this it's not that anything
is particularly offensive or makes me
feel bad I'm actually very okay with
with that but I would say my values that
when you come into my home that we have
open conversation and we we discuss the
things those elephants so maybe having
that sitting down with the your
father-in-law and saying
the last conversation we said was that I
was something this was something you
were going to take to your grave
I need you to know this is something
that you will see and experience if
you're in my home
and then if on log is to decide what he
does next
I think that's it who do I pay
and here's the deal
you've spent your whole life making sure
other people are okay
that kept you from getting killed
and so you still have an inclination to
make sure everybody around you is all
right
and if you and I were sitting down and
we had longer to spend together
I would ask you or well I'll just ask
you here are you interested in you've
said several times like I wanted this
just to be done
was that a was that shame talking or is
that man I really
don't like the way this
compulsive Behavior builds up in me uh
shame and fear and since I've been
expressing myself more I get more
outward love from everyone in my across
communities
um
it's it's almost affirming Behavior
right and that's that's some of the the
psychology that people come out against
is that right now we're in a season when
it feels so good so many people come up
and high five you that it it all it
reinforces your body like ah I'm extra
safe right you see what I'm saying sure
yeah
so I guess I guess what I'll tell you is
man
you and your wife have to come to some
sort of agreement on here's who we are
and here's who we're going to be
and here's what's here's what we talk
about in our home here's what we don't
talk about in our home
and then
like millions and millions and millions
of people you've got to decide are we
gonna let in law A and B come in our
house and make their political jokes and
complain about the food and whatever and
if we're just gonna do it for a weekend
that's fine
no they're great I love them I I I I
really do feel resolution in in hearing
just that that simple statement to to
tell them hey last time we had the
discussion it seemed like something that
you might take to your grave but when
you're in our home it's something that
you might experience and be around
and I want you to know I love you guys
could not have asked for better in-laws
and
it's important to me in our house that
everybody is safe to talk
yeah and I mean it's great and expect
there to be pushback and maybe maybe not
but I would I would expect that that
sounds does that sound fair
yeah 100 okay are you seeing somebody
for the anxiety I'm not I've seen people
over time uh for for periods this time
and then kind of float in and out I
guess covet kind of disrupted that it
for a bit okay
hold your little one
five months
here's what I can almost guarantee has
happened when your wife got pregnant
that the uh actually you said the
compulsion there
your body remembers
your body remembers the abuse your body
remembers the hurt your body remembers
the exclusion your body remembers all of
it
and it will recall those stories with
your little one that's why I'm so
hesitant to say like this is just me
versus this is how my body's trying to
stay safe
it's a way it releases this anxiety okay
here's what I'm telling you I believe
that I want you to go
sit with somebody who's good a mental
health professional that's good
now hear me say I don't think you have a
mental health disorder because you enjoy
wearing women's clothes I think anyone
who says that's incorrect
I think you are
desperate to stop feeling so anxious all
the time is that fair
yeah okay
there's a guy who's gone through Seasons
when I couldn't breathe
being so anxious I can't breathe
and I try to solve it with a flurry of
activity both in my head and both in
action
you get exhausted and I get exhausted
I get low and the whole cycle repeats
again
someone should reach out to somebody and
say it's a new baby my childhood was
unfathomable
I want to have peace
for the first time in my life I want to
have peace
and I've laid a great Foundation I don't
owe anybody any money I've got a family
who loves me I've got a ride or die wife
she even laughs at me she's great got a
kid who loves me a kid who's healthy
I'm ready to find peace Matt you are
worth that your little one's worth that
your wife is worth that
foreign
thank you for being brave thank you for
being courageous and saying these things
out loud I know this stuff's hard and
you had these these you've had this in
your soul for a long time thank you so
much you're uh willingness to have open
conversations is going to help a lot of
people
if I can ever help in any way holler at
me man hey uh send him a copy of own
your pass change your future too hand on
the line Matt and Jenna's gonna get you
a copy of that for free on me and um
give it a read and let me know what you
think thank you so much for your call
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as you wrap up today's show
one of the greatest songs ever ever I
remember being a little kid playing air
guitar in my neighbor's house to this
song
rocked it
the great Bon Jovi the song's called You
Give Love a Bad I love this song you
give love that name
let's do it all all dramatic
shot through the heart
and you're to blame you
Give Love a Bad Name an angel's smile is
what you sell you promised me heaven but
you put me through hell and the chains
of Love Got a Hold on Me and when
passions of prison you can't break free
oh
you're a loaded gun oh there's nowhere
to run
no one can save me the damage is done
shot through the heart and you're to
blame
y'all don't give love a bad name y'all
are actually incredible hey I love you
guys stay in school don't do drugs bye
foreign